j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
dans ce sens public on va analyser
décortiquer la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel avec mes invités experts
les arguments juridiques les
conséquences politiques l'avenir du
mouvement social mais d'abord on vous
explique comment ce texte s'est retrouvé
entre les mains des 9 sages de la rue
Montpensier
rarement une décision du Conseil
constitutionnel aura été aussi attendu
pour beaucoup la vie des sages va faire
office de juge de paix après trois mois
de contestation sur la réforme des
retraites le Conseil constitutionnel
doit dire si le texte est conforme ou
non à la Constitution et l'institution a
dû examiner quatre recours le premier
émane du gouvernement c'est une saisine
qui vise à afficher la confiance de
l'exécutif en son texte mais les autres
recours sont plus politiques la gauche
sénatoriale en a déposé un pour dénoncer
l'incincérité des débats au Sénat
c'est-à-dire un examen tronqué de la loi
qui se serait produit dans des
conditions dégradées on a appuyé
particulièrement sur ce qui s'est passé
au Sénat et notamment sur cette nuit
qu'on a appelé un peu la nuit du la nuit
du chaos sur cette nuit du 7 du 7 mars
sur l'article 7 pendant cette nuit tout
s'est emballé par une volonté d'utiliser
tous les dispositifs qui étaient à la
disposition à la fois de la Constitution
à la fois du Règlement du Sénat pour
nous empêcher de débattre côté Assemblée
nationale le RN et la nu pont aussi
déposer de recours les députés estiment
avoir été privés d'un débat nécessaire à
la chambre basse la coalition de gauche
a aussi attaqué le texte sur le fond
pour ma part j'ai
ainsi fan homme
qui je le rappelle est quand même
constitutionnel c'est-à-dire que dans La
Linea 3 de la constitue du Préambule de
la Constitution il est noté que la loi
garantie à la femme dans tous les
domaines des droits égaux à ceux de
l'homme et j'ai fait la démonstration
devant les sages que cette réforme
pesait davantage sur les femmes que sur
les hommes le Conseil constitutionnel
peut choisir de censurer tout ou partie
de la réforme mais en plus de ses
recours les sages doivent aussi valider
ou non le référendum d'initiative
partagée une ultime procédure sur
laquelle syndicat et parlementaire
d'opposition mise pour remporter la
bataille voilà sujet signé Jonathan
Dupriez j'accueille Franck Morel bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes avocat
associé chez Flichy Grangé ancien
conseiller social d'Édouard Philippe à
Matignon et expert emploi à l'Institut
Montaigne Mathilde Hitman patin bonsoir
bienvenue à vous vous êtes professeur
agrégés de droit public Bastien François
bonsoir bienvenue également professeur
de sciences politiques à l'Université
Paris impantéon Sorbonne Mathieu
croissant d'eau évidemment à mes côtés
cette dernière minute en étant en direct
et on vous fait vivre la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel l'Inter
syndicale demande à Emmanuel Macron de
ne pas promulguer la réforme des
retraites on va détailler à la fois la
décision
principalement on va dire la mesure
essentielle la mesure phare le report de
l'âge légal à 64 ans a été validé par le
Conseil constitutionnel en revanche le
référendum d'initiative partagée
première mouture telle qu'elle avait été
proposée par les parties de l'opposition
de gauche a été retoquée par le Conseil
constitutionnel il y a une deuxième
mouture qui a été déposée et la décision
du Conseil interviendra le 3 mai ça
c'est vraiment en de très grandes lignes
l'essentiel des informations de cette
fin d'après-midi je commence par les 64
ans Frank Morel qu'est-ce que vous que
pensez-vous comment vous analysez la
décision d'une sages est-ce que vous
est-ce qu'ils font de la politique ou
est-ce qu'ils font tout simplement du
droit de toute façon les décisions de
conséquences institutionnelle sont
toujours des décisions qui se fondent
sur une juridique mais qui interviennent
dans un contexte politique et le Conseil
constitutionnel ne fait jamais
totalement abstraction ce qui est bien
logique ce qui est bien évident de ce
contexte politique en la matière la
réaction qu'on peut avoir par rapport à
la décision et la suivante on avait
toute une série de griefs qui portait
sur la procédure d'adoption du texte le
Conseil rejette ses grillages en
indiquant que alors il y a plusieurs
éléments qui sont mis en avant mais
notamment que le cumul d'usage de
plusieurs procédures n'a pas par
lui-même ce cumule produit grief
engendré un grief qui serait de nature à
considérer que le texte est
inconstitutionnel ensuite le Conseil
valide l'essentiel du dispositif de la
loi mais il invalide 6 articles ou
partis d'articles
qu'il considère comme étant ce qu'on
appelle des cavaliers sociaux c'est à
dire qu'ils n'ont pas leur place dans
leur tête dans le texte et par la même
et c'était quand même quelque chose qui
était attendu par plusieurs analystes
dans les scénarios les plus probables
c'était un scénario qui était souvent
mis en avant par la même il crée une
forme de déséquilibre puisque les
dispositions qui sont invalidées sont
des dispositions qui ont très à l'emploi
des seniors il y a l'index seniors il y
a le CDI Senior et sont notamment une
disposition qui a très à l'usure
professionnelle avec le fond de
prévention de l'usure professionnelle et
donc j'ai envie de dire c'est peut-être
paradoxalement une forme de chance pour
le gouvernement parce que ça peut donner
du carburant à des discussions qui
peuvent faire suite avec les partenaires
sociaux à cette décision puisque on se
trouve désormais avec une réforme qui
est amputée des mesures qui n'étaient
déjà pas très nombreuses mais bon des
mesures sur l'emploi des seniors et de
certaines mesures sur l'usure
professionnelle et il va falloir combler
ce vide ça ça déséquilibre en partie la
réforme et le texte donc on verra ce
qu'ils ressort parce que pour l'instant
je le rappelle aussi ça fait partie des
informations de cette fin d'après-midi
Emmanuel Macron avait proposé à
l'intersyndical une rencontre mardi
prochain le 18 et pour l'instant
l'intersyndicale dit non on veut faire
ça après la prochaine grande
mobilisation qui aura lieu à priori le
1er mai jour de la fête du Travail
Mathilde patin vraiment avec l'analyse
de la constitutionnaliste que que vous
êtes est-ce que est-ce que vous vous
attendiez parce que c'était
effectivement le scénario le plus
souvent présenté mais certains disaient
mais il y a matière pour retoquer
l'ensemble de cette de cette réforme
est-ce que finalement voilà vous
attendiez à une décision comme celle-là
oui j'ai mis attendais mais c'est vrai
qu'il y avait matière c'est-à-dire que
comme vous le disez comme vous le disiez
il y a une une partie politique de la
décision du Conseil d'interprétation et
cette interprétation peut conduire à
choisir un axe plutôt qu'un autre on
aurait pu imaginer une censure totale de
la loi sur deux objets l'utilisation
d'une noix de financement rectificatif
de la sécurité sociale d'une part ou
d'autre part l'utilisation de l'article
47-1 dans les délais donc obligé à
examiner la réforme en 50 jours il y
avait un précédent qui était assez
intéressant c'est une décision de 1985
où le Conseil constitutionnel était
amené à traiter d'une noix de règlement
et cette loi de règlement qui est une
loi de financement avait été utilisée
avec l'article 47 dans des délais
contraints et le Conseil avait dit mais
il n'y avait pas d'urgence parce que il
n'y avait pas de question de continuité
de la vie de la nation au 1er janvier à
avoir adopté ces mesures donc les délais
n’étaient pas applicables on aurait pu
imaginer que le Conseil fasse le choix
de transposer cette décision au cas elle
va financement de sécurité sociale
est-ce que François vous faisiez partie
de celles et ceux qui imaginaient une
censure totale non
mais je suis comme ma collègue il y
avait des matières il y avait matière
mais pour le faire il fallait que le
Conseil constitutionnel et une
interprétation on va dire assez
constructive la Constitution qui ne se
contente pas d'une lecture très
littérale c'est à dire qu'il anticipe
aussi éventuellement les effets de sa
décision sur des usages à venir etc donc
là le Conseil constitutionnel a eu ils
ont une lecture un peu conservatrice du
texte ou prudente ça dépendra comment on
voudra le prendre
très lecture très littérale
franchement il fait vraiment le minimum
c'est à dire que voilà on peut aussi
comprendre pourquoi il le fait
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une énorme
pression c'est très compliqué les sous
sous le regard non seulement de tout le
monde enfin de tous les citoyens on a vu
les attentes que ça suscité mais
évidemment sous le regard tous les jeux
bon et peut-être il est encore plus peur
de ça que du reste donc non non il a une
lecture
peut-être un peu décevante à vrai dire
moi je trouve que la décision alors là
on l'a lu très très rapidement parce que
elle est assez longue mais je trouve que
c'est une décision pas très très
intéressante très plate
mais c'est fait exprès c'est pas que les
les conseillers constitutionnels voilà
ils ont fait exprès de faire quelque
chose avec très peu de points d'accroche
pour que justement les critiques un peu
glissent sur la télévision est-ce que
c'est pas là où il aurait fait de la
politique le Conseil constitutionnel
ça dépend ce qu'on appelle faire de la
politique c'est à dire que le texte une
constitution c'est un texte politique
bon il l'interprète il interprète avec
une contrainte qui n'est pas la vôtre
par exemple c'est que il l'interprète
avec la contrainte de d'être obligé de
parler en droit c'est-à-dire de trouver
des arguments juridiques ça c'est une
contrainte particulière du Conseil
constitutionnel ils n'en reste pas moins
que ça quand même un texte politique
qu'on interprète bon et ce texte
politique qu'on interprète évidemment il
est reçu son cette interprétation elle
est reçue politiquement bon donc bien
sûr chaque fois que le Conseil
constitutionnel surtout si la question a
déjà construite elle est déjà dans
l'espace public elle fait l'objet de
débat évidemment c'est c'est toujours
des décisions politiques mais c'est pas
des décisions politiques au sens de
rivalité
partisanes etc voilà mais pardon je vous
en prie pour rebondir sur sur ce que
vous disiez sur la potentialité
d'utiliser la loi de financement
rectificative de sécurité sociale parce
que ce que dit la décision c'est le
conseil vérifie qu'il y a les
dispositions obligatoires mais ça ne
veut pas dire que le législateur ne pas
faire ne peut pas faire autre chose et
moi en tant que Conseil constitutionnel
je n'ai pas à substituer ma propre
appréciation à celle du législateur
c'est quelque chose qui revient
extrêmement régulièrement et donc
finalement c'est une ouverture nous en
discussion du fait que finalement
beaucoup de choses pourraient rentrer
par cette voie à partir du moment où les
dispositions
[Applaudissements]
lorsqu'on est compare au mode de
nomination de la Cour constitutionnelle
allemande italienne espagnole belge on
peut nommer des anciens minnismes mais
il me semble-t-il si je regarde ce qui
se fait dans les autres pays européens
après un délai de carence c'est-à-dire
passer directement de ministre à membres
du Conseil là problème le président
Badinter président du Conseil
constitutionnel avait cette formule les
membres du Conseil doit avoir à deux
voir d'ingratitude à l'égard des
personnes qui les ont nommées
Franck Morel est-ce qu'il faut changer
le système
français me paraît par rapport à
d'autres systèmes quand on pense par
exemple aux États-Unis ou les juges de
la Cour suprême sont nommés à vie et où
on voit toutes les difficultés qui
peuvent exister justement par rapport à
un déséquilibre ce qu'il faut noter en
France quand même c'est que comme notre
pays a connu au cours des 20 30
dernières années beaucoup d'alternance
et bien la composition du Conseil
constitutionnel souvent a été à
contre-courant de ce qu'était le pouvoir
politique Robert Badinter présidait le
conseil constitutionnel quand Jacques
Chirac était irrelan Dumas quand Jacques
Chirac était président Jean-Louis Debré
présidentel quand François Hollande
était président et donc cette nomination
a des échéances régulières avec les
alternances politiques fait que il y a
un brassage et donc et quand on regarde
en plus un peu plus dans le détail la
composition et la provenance des
différents des 9 membres du Conseil
constitutionnel on constate oui qu'il y
a des an ministre il y a deux anciens
Premier ministre l'un de gauche l'autre
de droite et il y a des juristes
éminents il y a une personne qui était
une dirigeante des services de
l'Assemblée nationale pas que mais il y
a aussi des gens qui ont été nommés qui
sont pas tous très connus du grand
public mais bon bien sûr il y a aussi
des personnes qui ont été nommées sans
qu'elles aient eu fortement un parcours
politique
à l'origine donc moi je considère que
c'est un mode de fonctionnement qui est
plutôt intéressant le rôle du Conseil
constitue d'ailleurs c'est accru au fil
des années les décisions des années 70
qui a accru qui a élargi le bloc de
continuité et puis la
QPC et pour l'instant c'est une
institution qui a plutôt trouvé sa place
et qui fonctionne mais qui a dû rendre
sa décision avec une pression bien sûr
et avec un dispositif policier je crois
quand même des membres à la fois
impressionnants et inquiétants sur
l'état de confiance dans nos
institutions il disait que quand on est
dans l'œil du cyclone et bien on est
dans le calme puisque l’œil dans le
cyclone dans le calme d'accord vous
voulez intervenir sur cette question du
mode de nomination je suis d'accord avec
vous sur le fait qu'il y a pire ailleurs
ça ne veut pas forcément dire qu'on ne
peut pas améliorer un petit peu le mode
de nomination c'est vrai que la plupart
des membres ont un parcours juridique
c'est pas pour autant qu'il ne faudrait
pas l'ajouter dans notre droit qu'il
faut avoir des compétences même si on
sait qu'il y a un service juridique
extrêmement compétent qui les appuis en
revanche là on pourrait améliorer c'est
celle c'est la réforme de 2008 la
réforme de 2008 notamment pour les
nominations du président les commissions
compétentes des assemblées doivent se
prononcer mais les modalités de vote
font de manière à ce que ce soit
extrêmement compliqué de s'y opposer et
on a vu une commission s'opposer à une
nomination qui finalement a été possible
parce que le jeu des majorités l'a
permis bon allez on va avancer parce que
et passer aussi au contenu finalement de
la décision et et de cette réforme et
aux conséquences politiques de la
décision du Conseil considère je propose
à terme traduit de nous rejoindre on est
en direct et on fait vivre les formation
évidemment de cette fin d'après-midi ou
là je vous ai surprises vous étiez un
tout petit peu plus loin que juste
derrière le rideau rebonsoir table donc
les toutes dernières infos on attend
voilà vos explications voilà on a appris
et bien tout d'abord que le gouvernement
entendait remettre sur le métier tout ce
qui concernait l'emploi des seniors et
qui a donc été invalidé car considéré
comme cavalier sociaux donc notamment
l'index et Seigneur l'article 2 ou
encore le CDI senior l'article 3 ça
reste la priorité donc on peut les
attendre dans un prochain projet de loi
sur le plein emploi on voit également et
bien que si le Gouvernement considère
que c'est la fin du cheminement
institutionnel et démocratique c'est ce
qu'a dit Elisabeth borne et bien ni
l'opposition ni l'intersey syndicale ne
désarme pour l'instant l'Inter syndical
à travers la voix de Sophie Binet a
demandé à Emmanuel Macron de ne pas
promulguer la réforme et puis je vous
donne quelques réactions politiques
Marine Le Pen pour qui et bien le sort
politique de la réforme n'est pas
scellée il appartiendra au peuple de
préparer l'alternance dit-elle Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lui qui tacle le Conseil
constitutionnel qui dit que le Conseil
est plus attentif à la monarchie
présidentielle au besoin de la monarchie
présidentielle qu'au besoin du peuple
souverain que la lutte continue doit
rassembler ses forces également Boris
Vallot un président du groupe PS à
l'Assemblée la crise reste ouverte
retirée cette loi merci beaucoup Tam
pour pour ces dernières informations
Bastien François si on parle maintenant
des de ce qui peut se passer dans les
dans les prochains jours et dans les
prochaines semaines Mathieu nous disait
tout à l'heure que selon toutes
vraisemblance le président de la
République va promulguer très rapidement
ça serait logique que ce soit peut-être
peut-être des week-ends
est-ce que c'est alors ce sera un
nouveau temps de mobilisation syndicale
sans doute qui va s'ouvrir une nouvelle
stratégie à inventer pour l'Inter
syndicale moi je dirais d'abord que on
voit bien que on a dit pendant des
semaines le Conseil constitutionnel va
va régler la crise en fait il n'a pas
réglé il n'a pas aggravé peut-être
ce qu'il avait fait une censure totale
là je pense que le gouvernement et le
président de la République aurait été
dans une position franchement très
difficile mais il n'a pas il n'a pas
réglé et je pense j'ai un petit peu peur
des réactions moi qui va y avoir sur le
le
sur le rip le fait de partager pour la
première mouture a été validé mais on
voit bien comment le 49-3 a été reçu
comme quelque chose de très agressif de
très antidémocratique de voilà là les
gens qui sont pas juristes qui n'iront
pas la décision et donc ne comprendront
pas nécessairement l'argumentation du
Conseil constitutionnel bon ben ils vont
recevoir ça comme je un nouveau déni de
démocratie en quelque sorte on nous
interdit nous exprimer sur le sujet donc
la situation la situation est pas simple
en fait c'est une sorte de victoire à la
Pyrrhus là quand même ce ce pour le
gouvernement parce que il y a un champ
de ruine il y a une très grande défiance
entre le gouvernement et les partenaires
la façon dont ça se passe à l'Assemblée
nationale au Sénat on voit qu'il y a des
très fortes tensions là actuellement il
y a quand même le une nomination
à la tête de l'ADEME qui a été refusé
par une majorité supérieure aux 3/5
c'est la première fois qu'on applique la
réforme enfin c'est pas qu'on applique
mais que et qu'elle a pour effet
d'empêcher une nomination en forme de
2008 bon
il y a toute une série de petits
épisodes on voit des alliances entre LR
et l'opposition pour contrer le
gouvernement là on a eu dans récemment
là je crois que c'était hier ou
avant-hier sur sur la loi de
programmation militaire ou voilà qui est
donc il y a il y a des membres du groupe
Renaissance qui ont quitté le membre et
qui le groupe et qui sont maintenant
simplement associés au groupe donc il y
a quand même beaucoup de petits indices
qui montrent que le parc la vie
législative du gouvernement là va être
de plus en plus difficile la vie sociale
aussi parce que j'avais raison
d'ailleurs la première ministre on a
bien conscience on peut pas se remettre
tout de suite là négocier donc ça veut
dire que
ça va être très très compliqué de sortir
de la crise on en est pas sorti en tout
cas votre avis là-dessus Franck Morel là
on est dans une situation de blocage et
peut-être kebanel Macron est en train de
tomber dans dans son propre piège
politique c'est à dire qu'il a il a
théorisé une forme d'affaiblissement des
corps intermédiaires et puis aujourd'hui
il en a besoin il a fait en sorte
d'affaiblir les partis politiques
traditionnels qui étaient enfin que sont
le parti socialiste ou LR et finalement
ils ont fait défaut pour LR pour voter
cette réforme et éviter le 49-3 il est
tombé dans son piège est-ce que vous
étiez on n'est pas on n'est pas rendu si
je prends une expression courante par
rapport à la fin de cette séquence ceci
étant cette étape est importante puisque
elle va se solder comme ça a été dit
tout à l'heure par le fait que le texte
va être promulgué et donc la question
qui
alors reste à savoir comment ce scénario
va s'écrire dans les prochains jours
mais je pense qu'on est rentré quand
même dans une dans une période
différente les corps intermédiaires pour
le coup les organisations syndicales ont
montré qu'elles avaient la capacité de
réguler ce mouvement et c'est une grande
différence par rapport à la période
gilet jaune où on était dans un
mouvement qui dès le départ était
déstructuré c'était lancé en dehors des
organisations syndicales là dès le
départ on était dans quelque chose qui
était organisé par les organisations
syndicales et qui est restée malgré
quelques échauffourés à certains moments
mais globalement
de mobilisation globalement très
largement organisé et maîtrisé par les
organisations syndicales il faut s'en
féliciter et donc on voit bien que on
rentre dans une nouvelle étape et chacun
des acteurs va avoir des préoccupations
différentes par rapport à la à l'étape
qui est en train de s'achever alors on
va rester sur la stratégie et la marge
de manœuvre on va dire du président de
la République je vous propose
un élément une réaction il était en le
président en visite sur le chantier de
la cathédrale Notre-Dame 84 années après
l'incendie et le chef de l'État on a
profité pour glisser un message quand
même assez clair regardez déjà fait on
continue
rien
lâcher c'est ma devise avec un grand
sourire on se doute bien qu'il y a le
double sens il parle pas seulement de
Notre-Dame Mathieu et puis une heure
après il propose au syndicat de de le
retrouver mardi bon il est sur quelle
stratégie même je pense que le naturel
pound Notre-Dame et on a un président
qui ne lâche rien le problème c'est
qu'on fasse on a des manifestants et
syndicats qui ne lâchent rien donc c'est
ce qu'on appelle une situation blocage
après moi je pense qu'on peut interroger
la sincérité du geste présidentiel
aujourd'hui hier les syndicats ont
demandé par la voie de leur berger un
délai de décence on sait qu'ils
attendaient plutôt le 1er mai pour
mobiliser et Emmanuel Macron leur temps
Lama avant-hier il leur promet à juste à
Amsterdam un échange un échange c'est
pas une négociation c'est pas une
discussion c'est pas une réunion c'est
un échange on constater les points de
désaccord dans un esprit de concorde
donc avec l'unité des cœur et les
volonté et puis aujourd'hui il joue en
fait à qui est le plus fermé qui est le
plus obtu et qui est le plus sympa donc
c'est on est vraiment dans une mise en
scène de communication le jour de la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel de
dire je vous tends la main venez mardi
regardez et après pour aller au français
regardez ces syndicats ce le camp de
l'irresponsabilité comme il les appelait
ils refusent refusé qui refuse alors que
lui-même a refusé lui mars la lettre de
l'intestindicale bref on est encore dans
un jeu tactique la vraie question
jean-philis c'est est-ce que cette
exécutif va considérer que nous sommes
en période de crise je le disais tout à
l'heure c'est important c'est pas rien
de le dire Elizabeth borne dit que le
pays est en convalescence on sent dans
son discours dans ce qu'elle peut dire
que elle a pris la d'une certaine façon
de ce qui se passe dans le pays dans la
parole officielle d'Emmanuel Macron qui
ne s'est pas encore exprimée sur le
sujet ou en tout cas par petites phrases
petit bout et où le ce qu'on avait
entendu lors de son interview télévisé
on a pas l'impression qu'il partage ce
diagnostic on a l'impression qu'il dit
que la loi suivi son cheminement
démocratique normal là ça décision va
être confortée son choix va être
conforté par par la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel on sait qu'il doit
s'adresser aux Français est-ce que ce
sera en début de semaine prochaine et
sous quelle façon ça reste encore en
suspens mais est-ce qu'il va dire aux
Français voilà on passe à autre chose
les retraites c'était dur à faire mais
je les fais et basta ou est-ce qu'il va
dire ok j'ai compris que on est dans une
situation particulière de crise parce
que de ce diagnostic dépendra ensuite
l'attitude des syndicats il y a un
exercice de sincérité de la part du
président ou d'objectivité s'il peut
objectiver la situation dans ce sens là
à faire avant de pouvoir reconstruire le
début d'un dialogue et pour l'instant je
le rappelle l'Inter syndical demande au
Président solennellement de ne peut pas
promulguer la loi réformant les
retraites et appelle les salariés à
faire du 1er mai et là encore je cite le
communiqué de l'interlical une journée
de mobilisation exceptionnelle et
populaire contre la réforme des
retraites et pour la justice sociale
elle décide d'ici là de ne pas accepter
de réunion avec
l'exécutif bah c'est François voulait
intervenir sur cette notion peut-être de
marge de manœuvre d'un Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui je suis globalement d'accord
avec cette analyse mais je voudrais
rajouter un point peut-être qui est la
question de la confiance aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que on a une crise de
confiance majeure
la parole présidentielle quand même elle
a de moins en moins de
de capacité à faire à transformer le
réel il a utilisé déjà dans des crises
importantes des coûts qui étaient assez
bien joué le grand débat national la
convention citoyenne sur le climat mais
c'est des coups qu'on peut pas rejouer
là donc il y a effectivement il y a la
difficulté c'est la pour moi majeur se
met du point de vue du gouvernement le
président de la République c'est la
question de la confiance or la confiance
on sait très bien c'est quelque chose
nous partageons tous dans notre vie ça
ne s'invente pas ça se décrète voilà et
donc plein d'autres choses peuvent se
décréter on peut faire des réunions on
peut faire trop peu on peut proposer des
politiques publiques on peut baisser ou
augmenter des impôts mais la confiance
ça se passe pas comme ça or il me semble
que le gros problème actuellement le
problème majeur dans la situation qui
est aussi un résultat de cette crise
c'est
on est de plus en plus on s'enfonce dans
plus de plus en plus dans une crise de
confiance qui me concerne d'ailleurs pas
que le qui concerne toutes les
institutions si le Conseil constitution
lié échappe à mon avis c'est que les
gens savent pas nécessairement qu'on
leur pose des questions pendant les
sondages qu'est-ce que c'est que le
Conseil
constitutionnels
que partiellement et ça ça pose un
énorme problème mais je veux dire pour
la société et même pour la
reconstruction de quelque chose dans un
camp ou dans l'autre je reste sur cette
idée de de capacité du président de la
République à voilà à trouver une une
voie de sortie sur cette ligne de crête
compliquée de ce printemps Mathilde
Hitman tata peut-être sur les outils
constitutionnelles ou
en sa possession sachant que on a le
sentiment que le 49-3 et est banni du
vocabulaire pour pour peut-être quelques
mois voire plus donc voilà comment
peut-il continuer à réformer le pays
sans majorité à l'Assemblée et 149-3
alors banni du vocabulaire je ne sais
pas parce que finalement
en tout cas oui encore faut-il
qu'Elizabeth borne continue avec Premier
ministre il peut peut-être changer la
donne
sur une autre loi mais si on refait un
projet de loi de finance rectificatif
en tout cas le conseil
le alors sur les outils politiques on
pourrait aussi imaginer que le président
mais je n'y crois pas demande une
nouvelle délibération aux assemblées
assez peu probable
et sinon
c'est un sujet qui est aussi important
abordé c'est mais qui n'est pas entre
les mains du Président c'est celui du
Rip et dire que le référendum initiative
partagé a été invalidé il y en a un
autre alors de savoir ce qui va en
devenir mais je m'avance peut-être un
peu non non vous avancez pas mais vous
m'offrez la transition puisque tu as
traduit les deux nouveaux elle sera
jamais autant intervenue j'espère
qu'elle est là à table que pendant
c'était cette émission et le rideau
s'ouvre est à m'apparaît c'est c'est
vraiment une spéciale spéciale Tam
superstar dans ton sens public donc pour
nous expliquer parce que c'est pas si
simple et puis surtout il faut pas qu'il
y ait de de peut-être de faux espoirs
sur ce qui peut se passer avec le
référendum d'initiative partager
expliquez-nous déjà ce qui s'est passé
il y a une première et une deuxième
version effectivement il y a eu une
seconde version qui a été déposée hier
au Sénat les parlementaires de à gauche
le pressentait la formulation de la
première demande de RIP qui a été
déposée le 20 mars dernier il y a ne
convenait pas car c'était un simple
article avec une phrase inscrivante à la
loi que l'âge de la retraite ne peut
être fixée au-delà de 62 ans et ça on
l'a bien compris le Conseil
constitutionnel a dit eh bien
actuellement en l'état du droit actuel
et bien l'âge est déjà de 62 ans donc la
demande est satisfaite et donc une
réforme c'est pas une réforme ce n'est
pas une réforme donc ils ont déposé une
deuxième demande de RIP une deuxième
demande qui est censée être plus
sécurisée au niveau juridique alors on
va un petit peu jouer au jeu des 7
erreurs on compare les deux alors le
titre a été légèrement modifié on est
passé d'une proposition de loi visant à
affirmer que l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite ne peut être fixé au delà de 62
ans à une proposition de loi visant à
interdire un âge légal de départ à la
retraite supérieure à 62 ans vous avez
des constitutionnalistes ils vont nous
dire si je trouve que ça change beaucoup
les choses
la formulation aussi du premier article
à ne change pas beaucoup elle est quasi
inchangée mais elle est surtout
complétée par un article 2 un article
qui lui changerait les choses selon la
gauche ça va créer un élément de réforme
puisque cela crée une nouvelle recette
fiscale liée aux ressources du capital
pour sécuriser le financement de la
retraite par répartition et donc là ça
change par rapport au droit existants
elle a été transmise au Conseil
constitutionnel avant la promulgation de
la loi donc pour la gauche on est
toujours dans les clous donc la question
c'est est-ce que ça passe est-ce que ça
change bon on va encore une fois pas se
prononcer pour les sages mais on a quand
même deux précisions à donner c'est que
le Conseil examine bien la deuxième
demande de RIP au regard de l'état du
droit d'hier donc avec la loi non
promulguée donc on est toujours dans
l'état du droit où l'âge légal c'est 62
ans mais ça passe puisque la loi n'est
toujours pas promulguée et si la
deuxième demande de parce que
normalement on n'a pas le droit de faire
un référendum d'initiative partagé si la
loi a été promulguée dans l'année
précédente voilà donc la deuxième
mouture elle sera examinée par le ça
passe
si le deuxième RIP est bien validé cela
ne pas l'application et bien de la
réforme des retraites et cela pendant
toute la campagne les 9 mois de recueil
des signatures et on attend en tout cas
toujours le verdict qui aura lieu le 3
mai pour avoir la décision du Conseil
constitution du Conseil console le 3 mai
merci Tam je crois que c'est votre
dernière intervention de la soirée mais
c'était parfait que vous soyez là
régulièrement et donc je vous redonne la
parole Mathilde Hitman patin parce que
on va se retrouver quand même là avec
une situation
particulière inédite puisque voilà ce
référendum d'initiative partagé ce n'est
jamais que la deuxième tentative la
première c'était pour la privatisation
d'Aéroport de Paris je le rappelle où on
va avoir une loi promulguée Mathieu le
rappelait tout à l'heure dans notre
première partie
éventuellement c'est ce qu'on peut
imaginer appliquer à partir du mois de
septembre et en parallèle l'espoir
qu'elle soit invalidée par une nouvelle
procédure on est en train de se
compliquer la vie quand même même si
c'est un outil de démocratie
participatif très bien mais on est quand
même un peu en train de se compliquer la
vie alors je d'un point de vue juridique
je vais peut-être décevoir les ce qui
espère il semble que le nouveau projet
ne remplissent pas les critères au sens
de la jurisprudence du Conseil je
m'explique brièvement le Conseil insiste
sur le fait qu'il faille une réforme là
la deuxième mouture cela a été rappelé
ajoute une modification d'une
participation à des frais de sécurité
sociale une augmentation d'un
pourcentage sauf que dans une décision
RIP 3 le Conseil avait jugé qu'une telle
modification une création d'une nouvelle
taxe n'était pas une modification
suffisante pour remplir le critère de
réforme donc vous que même la deuxième
mouture risque fort d'être invalidée
c'est une possibilité si le conseil en
s’en tient sa jurisprudence de réforme
je voudrais ajouter un point de
comparaison qui me paraît intéressant
c'est que ce mot réforme vous l'avez
aussi dans un autre texte qui n'est pas
de nature constitutionnelle mais qui
intéresse les questions sociales puisque
vous le trouvez dans l'article L numéro
1 du Code du travail qui dit que tout
projet de réforme qui touche les
questions de travail d'emploi et qui
rentrent dans le champ de la négociation
collective nationale
interprofessionnelle doit faire l'objet
tout d'abord d'une concertation et le
Conseil d'État a élaboré une doctrine
sur ce qu'il fallait entendre par
réforme et effectivement la doctrine du
Conseil d'État prend en considération le
fait qu'une réforme c'est d'une part
quelque chose qui modifie l'état du
droit mais qu'il modifie aussi de
manière un peu substantielle par exemple
le Conseil d'État a considéré que une
simple transposition directive
européenne ou un texte de déblocage
anticipé de la participation ne rentrez
pas dans cette définition de ce qu'est
une la forme et dans ce qui est
intéressant pour faire le parallèle avec
ça c'est qu'effectivement là on a les
deux aspects on a d'abord est-ce que ça
modifie l'état du droit et aujourd'hui
l'état du droit c'est 62 ans donc sur
l'article 1 l'état du droit n'est pas
modifié et j'abonde dans votre sens sur
l'article 2 la question c'est pas est-ce
que ça modifie l'état du droit c'est
est-ce que c'est suffisamment
substantiel et si on se réfère à ce qu'a
déjà décidé le Conseil constitutionnel
et le parallèle avec l'appréciation du
Conseil d'État on pourrait considérer
que ça n'est pas suffisamment
substantiel votre avis d'être Sébastien
François vouliez prendre d'avis
particulier mais les choses sont quand
même à mon avis ouvertes encore oui
parce que d'abord le Conseil
constitutionnel n'a pas donné de réforme
je dirais
définition de définition avec nom de la
réforme donc qu'est-ce qui est
substantiel pas substantielle dans quel
contexte aussi par rapport à quelle loi
aussi je pense ça pèse on y est pas
encore il va y avoir 15 jours parce que
c'est avant pendant ces 15 jours ça va
beaucoup discuter ça va beaucoup plus il
y aura une forme de pression populaire
beaucoup de pression
du 1er mai et sur ce point je crois très
franchement que
autant il y a des choses que tout le
monde peut comprendre autant que c'est
franchement incompréhensible pour un
citoyen de notre pays qu'on explique sur
un sujet politique aussi
considérable qu'on ne peut pas faire un
référendum sur les 62 ans parce que ça
va devenir vous voyez le référendum les
62 ans parce que ça serait pas une
réforme ben franchement c'est un
argument juridique qui est
incompréhensible conditionnel ne
prendrait peut-être pas le risque de de
d'attiser une colère sociale donc on se
la question de ça ça permet à visiter à
l'opinion et au contexte il y a des
petits revirements de jurisprudence le
le la décision qu'il avait prise
effectivement en matière fiscale
effectivement on peut la lire comme vous
venez de la lire bon je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec votre lecture de la
décision maintenant
on peut aussi éventuellement la lire
autrement et sans que ça apparaisse
comme quelque chose d'extrêmement
choquant donc il pourrait y avoir une
forme de petit revirement du risque
parce que je crois que là on va parler
pendant 15 jours que de ce sujet
maintenant pour le moment on a parlé que
des retraites à partir de ce soir c'est
le rip bon et donc pendant 15 jours tout
le monde dans tous les médias tous les
spécialistes et puis tout en plus tous
les spécialistes de démocratie parce que
maintenant c'est plus que c'est plus que
des questions de constitutionniste etc
tout le monde va s'y mettre
rappelez-vous quand même que les gilets
jaunes c'était le RIC donc le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne bon qui était
quand même extrêmement porté donc ce
thème il est déjà là il est déjà
extrêmement discuté et donc si on
explique aux Français que pour une
interprétation bizarroïde d'une phrase
elle-même qui ne dit pas grand chose de
la Constitution c'est les réformes sur
la politique sociale de la Nation pour
tous les Français normalement constitués
à partir du moment ils savent écrire
ça veut dire les retraites rentrent
là-dedans donc ça va être très compliqué
d'expliquer l'inverse oui mais alors je
voudrais quand même rappeler parce qu'on
est là aussi pour pour
ne pas donner d'illusions peut-être au
téléspectateurs Franck Morel on l'a dit
plusieurs fois sur ce plateau peut-être
pas assez dans d'autres médias mais
c'est pas parce que le Conseil
constitutionnel le 3 mai imaginons
valide le processus et donc le
référendum d'initiative partagé s'ouvre
que il y aura forcément au bout un
référendum même si 10% du corail le
signal vous avez vous avez bien que vous
nous l'expliquer
parce qu'effectivement le parcours est
un parcours extrêmement long et qui nous
sommes toutes assez peu de chances
d'aboutir indépendamment de la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel c'est-à-dire
que même dans l'hypothèse ou le Conseil
constitutionnel donnerait le feu vert le
3 mai sur la version numéro 2 donc pour
un référendum d'initiative partagé il y
a deux étapes substantielles la première
c'est le recueil de un peu moins de 5
millions de signatures 4,8 je crois 10%
du corps électoral donc ce qui est quand
même quelque chose d'assez ardu parce
que c'est pas simplement signé une
pétition comme on voit parfois c'est
remplir un formulaire c'est quelque
chose d'assez élaboré je sais pas si
vous avez je vais vous laisser continuer
mais je peux signal juste à la Régie
vous avez peut-être le sondage au doxa
pour Le Figaro qui qui nous dit les
trois quarts des Français 74% assure
qu'ils apporteraient certainement ou
probablement leur voix au rythme voilà
il va peut-être s'afficher mais ça il y
a ça fait quand même du monde
potentiellement ça fait du monde mais
entre eux
et pas que de le signer et de remplir un
formulaire c'est une démarche
extrêmement active dans un délai
contraint et puis ensuite
dans l'hypothèse où cette étape serait
franchie il reste la possibilité aux
deux assemblées à l'Assemblée nationale
et à au Sénat de se saisir du texte et
de le rejeter pour éviter un référendum
ce qui reste une possibilité donc ça
veut dire que il y a quand même un
parcours qui est quand même un parcours
extrêmement complexe long et la
probabilité
que un référendum soit effectivement
organisé dans quelques mois est très
faible d'autant plus que le comme vous
le disiez les assemblées que les
assemblées se saisissent du texte il
suffit d'un simple examen oui donc ça
veut dire que ça peut être mis à l'ordre
du jour par le gouvernement lors de ces
semaines comme le prévoit l'article 48
il suffit de quelque parlementaires qui
examine le texte et c'est fini il y a
même pas besoin d'un vote donc c'est
vraiment des une condition très très
facilement on peut quand même le bloquer
en commission mais est-ce que c'est pas
une machine à créer de faux espoirs ce
référendum en tout cas il a été il a été
créé pour qu'il marche pas enfin tout le
monde le sait
enfin je veux dire les débats l'ont bien
montré d'ailleurs les débats
constituants en 2008 bon il a été créé
pour qu'il ne marche pas
maintenant évidemment il prend un sens
différent et donc alors ceci étant même
si ça même si on n'y arrivait pas au
bout c'est quand même très probable
qu'on arrive pas au bout parce que bon
pour il y a tous ces obstacles mais ça
veut dire quand même 9 mois plus six
mois
où on parlera que des retraites où tous
les toutes les semaines il y aura les
chiffres et c'est quoi c'est jusqu'aux
Jeux olympiques mais avec la loi qui
sera rentrée en application et qu'est-ce
qui se passera bon donc c'est ça crée
quand même une très grande tension et là
je pense là il faudrait peut-être que le
gouvernement et le président de la
République trouve une petite solution
pour mettre en suspens l'application de
la loi retraite après tout c'est pour
dire c'est pour faire un équilibre en
2030 on pourrait se dire on reporte
simplement le début de l'application non
mais parce que sinon attendez si on est
si argument mais ça devient un an et
demi après sur des situations acquises
on aura demande il y aura des gens qui
ont refait deux trimestres de plus en
réalité et on leur dira bah non vous
auriez pu partir bon c'est très
compliqué ni vaincu à Elizabeth borne ce
soir c'est sans doute une des phrases
les plus justes qu'elle est prononcée
depuis qu'elle est à 21h parce que quand
on regarde l'exécutif est quand même
dans une situation extrêmement complexe
soit très bien décrite sans oublier
qu'on n'est pas dans un pays fracturé le
mariage pour tous est fracturé la
société il y avait des poids il y avait
les comptes là on a quand même une très
très grande majorité de l'opinion
publique des actifs du cœur battant de
la France qui sont opposés à cette
réforme les syndicats sont battus entre
guillemets mais c'est pas bon c'est bon
pour personne parce que ils ont nourri
un espoir quand même ils ont nourri même
si les Français semblaient dans toutes
les enquêtes d'opinion mon de résigner
parce qu'il savait que cette loi
passerait mais ça les a pensé de
s'opposer il y a toujours une part de
rêve une part d'espoir et on risque
d'ajouter peut-être avec cette affaire
de RIP si ça ne fonctionne pas de la
déception et des enchantements et
arriver sur un fond de défiance comme
vous le décriviez tout à l'heure et là
quand les gens se disent qu'il y a plus
de d'alternatives possible que rien ne
marche dans ce qui pourrait corriger le
système et voilà je pense que c'est de
plus en plus inquiétant on va terminer
là-dessus merci à tous c'était
passionnant de vous entendre analyser
voilà les conséquences de cette décision
du Conseil constitutionnel merci à tous
je vous souhaite une belle fin de soirée
et un bon week-end et puis lundi sur
notre antenne votre premier rendez-vous
politique ce sera dans la matinale
évidemment rien de Mancini reçoit
Olivier Faure le premier secrétaire du
Parti socialiste à très vite à lundi